okay let me just start with saying that
this movie Flatliners got a zero percent
on Rotten Tomatoes that is gonna bring
you to have incredibly low expectations
when you see this movie that's what
happened to me and honestly the
beginning of the movie I was really
enjoying I thought it was really well
done they got right to it they got right
to the whole flatlining scenario down in
the basement
it moved quick at a good pace solid set
of characters and it is a cool concept
from the original one where you're
flatlining right before death and you're
brought back to life but it's kind of
that white flash of what we see and what
happens but the special effects they're
not so great that looked like a 90s
movie whenever they would flatline and
go back in this different dimension all
these medical students get hooked to
doing this like a drug it kind of
becomes like it's the ecstasy it's this
new drug and hip ray was played by Diego
Luna from Star Wars rogue one kind of
the more sane realistic one like guys
this is dangerous like what are we doing
here let's be careful and I could hook
to this how to change your life and they
all just kind of down with it net when
Island page starts getting these
hauntings over sister and basically he
gets pushed off of the railing at our
apartment that is when the movie just
takes a complete turn and it becomes
this cheesy horror movie and everything
starts to not make sense and then the
movie goes from pretty good the first
about 40 minutes and then the last hour
was atrocious so I wouldn't say this
movie's a zero as bad as around tomatoes
is saying but it really fools you cuz I
was like wait maybe this is that
underdog story of a movie where it got
really by review so it's actually pretty
good so I thought in the beginning but
no no no then it gets really bad I mean
it would go to like a negative and run
to me as a second half of the movie
first off I don't understand why of the
hauntings and that's starting to happen
when I feel like it was just should just
go deeper into these hallucinations are
having and not bring this all up where
it becomes like ooh this spooky horror
movie it just seems like too good of a
concept to have that happen it's almost
wasted in a way I feel like someone
could have used this type of story
better and made something better out of
it and the problem is when you're
learning everyone's backstory on what's
causing this guilt that's causing the
hauntings of
when they've hurt I mean there were
certain parts like Marlow we find out it
was a jellyfish incident that she's
feeling bad about that makes it feel
like a Tim and Eric scare or something
you watch an adult so I'm like a parody
I was like really
what come on it's a jellyfish incident
she didn't take care of the patient
right away like there's certain things
you avoid in a serious movie and making
it a jellyfish thing just adds humor to
it not smart to go I don't know who in
the writers but yeah let's make it ah
the guy gets stung by jellyfish that guy
should be out of his job then Keefer who
was in the original Flatliners he's got
the best gig ever in this movie he's
just the teacher of all these medical
students every scene he does is in this
board room that's it and he has a cane
what a gig for him is an act he probably
got paid so much money for this and he
literally had that one onset location
for him good for key for bringing in the
money for that but man his scenes too
were just like not necessary he's just
basically reviewing everything almost as
like the recap guy for the movie itself
you start realizing as it goes along you
save yourself what was the point of that
what was the point of this they never
answered this they never did that you're
just like I don't understand what's
going on it's just kind of lost complete
focus and felt rushed and we'll really
did not make sense was how when Jamie
and Marlowe went to get forgiveness for
who they hurt Jamie sees the woman he
knocked up and the kid he finds out he
has and she's not about it she's not
forgiving him she hates her and the kids
like who is that and then when we see
Jamie to end the movie his story ends
with yeah be a good dad and I'm gonna be
living near them it's like how did it go
from that like they hate you
you weren't in their life or now
everything's all happy and yay Jamie's
back that made no sense we don't even
see how that resolves and then Marlowe
that was just too much with her being in
the this second dimension after life and
she's asking a jellyfish man for
forgiveness and he just kind of grabs
her it really wasn't any forgiveness so
again what what is this resolving just
don't make them more mad and go more
crazy I think but no they're just like
yeah and when Sophia goes to say sorry
she bullied the woman's like no I'm not
talking to you walks up and then
immediately just change their minds like
you're forgiven it's just a cheese
it's really cheesy and the actress of
Sofia I felt like could not hang with
the other actors and actresses I thought
she was very weak and not believable and
just watching her facial expressions and
certain scenes were just like
distracting in a way or she's just like
not match the tone of what each scene
was or who she was supposed to be
portraying at that given moment it just
felt like she was not fully invested in
the role and was really bringing down
some scenes and that's the thing Ellen
Page is your best actress in this movie
your lead and that's such a mistake when
you kill that character that early in a
movie can really hurt a movie and right
when she kicks the bucket Ellen page's
movie kicks the bucket so that has to
correlate in a way to maybe that's a
Miss cast maybe Ellen Page shouldn't
play that character maybe maybe his
lower level actress should have had her
role and on page has they're all that
finishes out maybe more those are all
what really frustrated me is Rhea was
the most likable character and we don't
find out anything about his character I
wanted to know if there was a twist that
maybe he did something bad why was he so
reluctant to using the flatlining
there's no meat there there's just
nothing and then it answered that
horrible scene where they're in the bar
and they hear the same song Ellen Page
was playing on the piano like woohoo and
they're ready like let's get drunk and
hammered and it just felt weird and
corny and all over the place but that
frustrated me the most was not knowing
anything about race character no
backstory for him and he seemed like the
most important character at a time but
he was kind of just the voice of reason
and that's it nothing else to him and
the Batman ending to with Marlo
narrating like you know Courtney really
taught us all a lesson and did good she
didn't really do good she kind of messed
up and you know what these people didn't
forgive these sinners as we would say
and in the end they throw out Courtney's
laptop into the ocean and they're all in
green to cover up the whole flatlining
thing what's no justice to Ellen page's
character or her family they don't know
what really happened to her so they're
just still being criminals in a way I
get it it makes sense like I don't want
them to do that yeah yeah let's cover it
up but it's still like you guys learned
anything isn't don't you feel a little
guilty about that too that
her family doesn't know what really
happened to her I don't know not about
the second half of the movie I did enjoy
the first half kept my intention was
suspenseful she's didn't I wish you
didn't take such a corny horror turn on
it I wouldn't give this a zero like our
on tomatoes has but I would give it a
four which is super low but because the
end the beginning team is pretty strong
okay at some points right so I'm gonna
give it a four but the end was so bad
that's gonna drop it way down and I
really hope they don't make a sequel for
this this is just a another Sony
Pictures just not doing well and it's
not gonna do good the box office
projects to get like two to four million
dollars so it's like geez
come on let's let's make more original
ideas here let's at least take the
concept maybe and switch it up a lot
more but they really didn't do that here
it's very lazy felt very rushed and
didn't know where it was going
I'll do for this review of Flatliners
please subscribe follow me at Steve
early one on Twitter and Instagram as
well for more I do movie reviews TV
reviews trailer reaction celebrity
interviews please keep coming back and
con blow with your thoughts on the movie
I respond to everybody let me know what
you thought agree me disagree with me
anything you want to say let it out here
I really appreciate any engagement you
coming back